[Music]
all right i'll take this next question i
think i may even make it the last
question all right let's see
okay this is a good day please i need
the answer to this question urgently in
anticipating
a response a reply and also
will like pastor randy skeet to answer
i am a college student
i'm a student in college this in the
country nigeria but due to the presence
of a corrupt system and greedy lecturers
in my school some illegally made it
compulsory for certain amounts of money
to be paid before a student could submit
his or her practical reports or
assignments is it a sin to pay such
money using the biblical explanation in
regards to bribery and extortion
yes it's a sin
now i realize you value your education
very highly and you're looking forward
to your degrees you can have a good job
there is no justification for violating
or drifting from dust set the lord the
bible speaks against bribes we must not
accept or pay bribes or accept bribes if
it is not if it's the political it
cannot be an official policy if some
corrupt teacher has introduced that as a
way of making money you cannot well you
can do it but you'd be wrong you must
not do it christians need to understand
doing right must be the standard we
follow even at the loss of life
and if daniel was willing to lose his
life to be faithful to god the three
hebrew boys were willing to lose their
life you must be willing to lose a
degree to be faithful to god do not pay
bribes to teachers don't do that put the
matter in god's hands and leave it in
god's hand your god is god your god is
not that degree god can take care of you
with or without a degree i'm not against
degrees i'm against compromising for the
sake of a degree like taking exams on
seven for the sake of the degree
on the god in first samuel 2 30. i hope
the person will read this verse them
that honor me i will honor believe that
and honor god do not pay a bribe or
accept one
amen amen